This video is made possible by BLINKIST.
The first hundred people go to BLINKIST.COM/VisualPolitik
are going to get unlimited access for one
week to try out.
Also get 25% off the full membership.
More about that later for now… let´s get
on with it.
Japan is the country with the greatest reason
to be scared of nuclear power.
Think about it, they have the biggest nuclear
trauma record in the world.
So far, they are the only country that has
suffered a nuclear attack.
Namely, the Hiroshima and Nagasaki bombings.
In fact, during the 50s, nuclear paranoia
was big in Japan.
The most famous outcome of this is the movie
Godzilla, the story of a gigantic radioactive
lizard that destroys cities.
Nonetheless, as the Japanese economy grew,
Japan started building its own reactors.
A couple of decades later, they became the
third biggest nuclear powerhouse, only surpassed
by America and France.
Yep, you heard that right.
While European countries like Germany were
organizing all kinds of anti nuclear demonstrations,
Japan blindly trusted uranium.
But then, while the Japanese were charmed
by atomic power, the unexpected happened.
Japan earthquake: Explosion at Fukushima nuclear
plant
A powerful explosion has hit a nuclear power
station in north-eastern Japan which was badly
damaged in Friday's devastating earthquake
and tsunami.
Overnight, nuclear panic came back to Japan
and the whole world.
And there was a good reason for it.
You see, during the Chernobyl accident in
1986, many people said “the problem isn’t
nuclear power--it’s the fact that Chernobyl
didn’t follow the security protocols: you
know the soviets…”
But Japan is a wealthy country that takes
extreme care with its security.
And despite all this care, Fukushima was still
a disaster.
All of a sudden, Japan shut down all of their
nuclear power plants.
They went from having 30% nuclear power in
their energy mix to a tiny 3%.
So now you might assume that Japan is turning
into an antinuclear country, right?
Well… in fact, the opposite is true!
20-22% share of nuclear power at core of updated
energy policy
Exactly!
Nuclear power has come back to Japan!
In fact, not only Japan… as we said in previous
videos, the whole Asian continent is going
through a nuclear revolution.
And when I say the whole continent, I mean
it, from wealthy countries like Japan to poor
countries like Bangladesh.
And this is surprising if we take into account
that nuclear reactors are far from cheap.
In this other video, we told you what’s
going on in China, but today we’re going
to focus on what’s happening in the other
two biggest Asian countries, Japan and India.
Because the question we want to address now
is What about nuclear power appeals to Asians
so much?
And how has India, still a poorer country,
become such a nuclear powerhouse?
Today, we are going to answer these questions
but, before we do, as always, let’s take
a look back at the history.
THE NUCLEAR GIANT IS BACK
Fukushima meant an immediate nuclear shutdown.
The Japanese wanted to minimize risk and stopped
all their reactors basically overnight.
So you might be wondering…
Where have they gotten their energy since
then?
I mean… how did they replace the energy
input they used to get from nuclear power?
The answer is a complete ecological HARA KIRI.
Yes, you heard that right!
If you thought nuclear power was bad for the
environment…
most of the alternatives are even worse.
Without uranium, Japan had to start using
fossil fuels.
This had two consequences: electricity prices
rose 20% because,suddenly, they had to buy
tons of liquefied natural gas.
The other consequence was that CO2 emissions
skyrocketed.
In other words… if Godzilla happened to
show up in Fukushima… he would have to wear
a mask.
And I know what you might be thinking…
Why don’t they use renewable sources?
What’s the problem with green energy?
Well… the problem is TIME.
If you wanna have solar panels and wind turbines,
first you have to build them.
And Japan is far behind other countries in
this matter.
In fact, it’s only NOW that they’re starting
their green energy plan.
Their goal is to achieve 22% of their energy
from renewable sources by 2030.
For a comparison, Europe plans to achieve
the same in 2020.
Why?
Mainly because Europe started investing in
these technologies way sooner.
But not only that!
Even if Japan wanted to speed up their green
energy plan, they couldn’t.
One of their main problems is red tape.
Want to start a wind turbine park?
You need 5 years of paperwork.
This is three times longer than most industrialized
countries.
And reducing red tape is almost impossible.
And let’s not forget to mention the classic
problem with green energy.
You know, that it’s very expensive to store
electricity using these methods.
For example, solar panels only give you energy
during the day and the same goes for wind
turbines: you only get energy when it’s
windy.
During a calm night, you still need other
energy sources.
So, realistically, Japan only has two options
for energy: they can keep importing expensive
gas and polluting like crazy or… they can
go nuclear!
And… the answer seems like a no brainer
for them…
Japan restarts five nuclear power reactors
in 2018
In total, at the time we made this video,
Japan has already restarted 9 nuclear reactors.
But it’s not only that they’re restarting
at the capacity they previously had…
They want to build even more!
Process begins at Shimane nuclear plant to
operate new reactor
You see, when you’re talking about nuclear
power, there’s one important thing you must
understand: they produce energy on an ongoing
basis.
This means, from the moment you start a reactor,
you have the same amount of energy every day.
No more, no less…
This is why nuclear power is considered the
base of an electric system.
Turning off a nuclear reactor is very expensive
and it’s only done when there’s a real
risk of an accident.
This is why they’re always producing energy
and… on top of that nuclear energy is where
we can add other energy sources like coal,
gas or green energy.
These are energy sources that can be adjusted
based on the energy demands on a particular
day.
Nonetheless, if we said green energy depends
on the weather, coal or gas depends on market
prices, which fluctuate daily.
Nonetheless, you just need a little piece
of uranium to have nuclear power, so price
fluctuations on this material don’t affect
the cost that much.
This is the reason why Japan is going back
to nuclear.
But not only Japan!
In South Korea, they are also mastering this
form of energy.
While in North Korea they build nukes, their
southern neighbours build reactors.
In total, they have 6.
And now you might wonder…
Who does build those nuclear power plants?
The truth is nuclear power is really complex
and expensive.
And there are very few companies that master
those technologies.
Do you remember those reactors built by Japan
in the 60s?
Well, they were built by British and American
companies.
For years, General Electric and Westinghouse
dominated the market.
But, soon, TOSHIBA, HITACHI and MITSUBISHI
started their own generation of models.
South Korea followed suit.
They started buying American, French and Canadian
models.
But then, HYUNDAY, DOOSAN and KEPCO started
manufacturing their own reactors.
Now South Korea is another nuclear powerhouse
that exports technology all over the world.
UAE and South Korea celebrate completion of
Barakah's first nuclear reactor
And now you might wonder…
OK but…
How much does a nuclear reactor cost?
To give you an idea, all the reactors that
they want to build in the Arabian Peninsula
cost 20 billion dollars: this is the cost
of an Olympic game.
Just to make a comparison, a fossil fuel plant
that generates the same amount of energy costs
20 times less.
Of course, producing a Kilowatt of electricity
with nuclear power is the cheapest way to
do so.
But the initial cost is only affordable to
very rich economies.
So then…
How on earth is it possible that India and
Bangladesh can have nuclear reactors?
Let’s have a look!
FROM GODZILLA TO GOGOLA
Japan has Godzilla: India has GOGOLA.
If you didn’t know, after the commercial
success of Godzilla, Bollywood created their
own exploitation version.
And this is the giant GOGOLA.
But enough with the movies!
When it came to energy, we had the same story.
If Japan had nuclear power plants, India wanted
the same.
The problem?
American companies didn’t want to sell reactors
to India!
Why?
Mainly because India has nukes.
Yes, you heard that right!
The country of Gandhi and non-violence is
one of the few nations with nukes.
And their biggest enemy, Pakistan, also has
them.
So there’s a real danger that one day they’ll
want to use them.
In other words, America doesn’t want to
help India go even more nuclear.
But that’s not even the most interesting
part!
You see, unlike Japan and South Korea, India
has its own uranium mines.
So, since America didn’t want to help them,
they went to France and Russia.
This is why many of the nuclear reactors in
India are built by ROSATOM, a Russian company.
But here’s the interesting part!
Indian reactors have something very special
about them: they’re cheaper than anywhere
else.
Why?
Because they’re the only ones that use NATURAL
URANIUM.
You see, most of the world’s reactors use
ENRICHED URANIUM.
This kind of uranium can’t be used to manufacture
bombs.
This is why buying enriched uranium is kind
of easy while there are many restrictions
on getting natural uranium
Basically, if you go to buy natural uranium,
they’ll tell you ‘Whoa, whoa, whoa, wait
a minute, cowboy!
Where are you going with that?
Do you want to make nukes, huh?
Leave this on the shelf and get outta here!’
But since India has its own uranium, they
can do whatever they want with it.
This is why their natural uranium reactors
are way cheaper.
And it explains news like this.
India plans tenfold uranium output growth
India is currently building 7 nuclear reactors
but they plan to build 20 more.
Yes, you heard that right: 20 brand new nuclear
reactors.
As I said, they’re using mainly Russian
technology.
And… you know, since Rosatom was doing business
in the region, they went to neighbouring Bangladesh
and made this.
Rosatom starts work on unit 2 of Bangladesh
n-project
With this, Bangladesh will cover 20% of their
energy demands with nuclear power.
And the same is happening with Pakistan.
Do you remember our previous video where we
told you China is starting to create its own
nuclear technology?
Well, Pakistan is the first one buying from
the Chinese.
In other words, nuclear power is not a rich
country business anymore.
Asia is going crazy over it.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video it
has been made possible, of course, by BLINKIST.
Do you manage to read all the books that you
want to read?
Probably not, right?
We all live busy lives and that sometimes
means you don’t get the knowledge you need.
It’s harder and harder to find the time
to read in the modern world.
I mean… all of those distracting videos
over there, on my left somewhere, really tempting
to click on.
The good news is that even if you don’t
have time, you can still learn with BLINKIST.
BLINKIST is an App that takes the best insights
you need to know from thousands non fiction
books and condenses them into 15 minutes which
you can either read or you can listen to.
They have a huge library and they’ve got
8 million users.
For me I’m probably the ideal BLINKIST customer…
I spend a lot of time working, making this
videos and far less time learning that I’d
probably should.
They’ve got tons of popular titles like
the four hour work week by Tim Ferres, that
I read a while ago and recapped recently.
There is also tons of political books, if
you wanna take a look back at the history
like we say here on VisualPolitik.
They have books condensed like SILK ROAD by
Peter Frankpan.
The first 100 to get BLINKIST.COM/VisualPolitik
are going to get unlimited access for 1 week
to try it out.
They also get 25% off the full membership.
May fast.
Grab one of this political books or whatever
you want, really.
The seven day trial is completely free and
you can cancel anytime during that trial if
you’re not satisfied.
But, you know, I’m sure you will be.
And, as always, thank you for watching.